raccoons are really smart they might
even be smarter than cats and dogs
scientists thought they were a unique
model for the evolution of the human
mind so they were popular research
animals and then raccoons got canceled
but raccoon research has been on the
rise especially in the last five years
or so and as it turns out we have plenty
to learn from their brains
the reason scientists gave up on
raccoons over a century ago well it all
goes back to this research paper from
1907. and they said something like all
of the research participants escaped
through the duct work they escape
through cages so often that researchers
ended up using rodents instead but
modern technology is helping behavioral
scientists study raccoons in new and
creative ways neuroscientists have also
figured out how to examine brains in
more detail making a strong case for
raccoons take this trash Bandit for
example he's trying to figure out how to
get those floating marshmallows out of
the tube he notices there are rocks on
the floor and rocks sink raising the
water levels just enough to grab the
treats experts think this shows that
raccoons have some understanding of
cause and effect like us my sprains are
pretty smooth but human and raccoon
brains have all these bulges and groups
that allows more brain cells to be
packed inside our souls more brain cells
means more processing power which
usually means higher intelligence the
raccoons check more of the boxes for
translating to human brains than the
rodents do a large part of both human
and raccoon brains are devoted to
sensing the world with our hands they've
got a lot of control and sensitivity
with those hands that's what helps them
climb trees and get into our trash so
easily
an experiment similar to this one
raccoons have to figure out how to open
a box each time they got it the
researchers changed the lock Kelly's
team found the raccoons are with the
best at opening boxes had more brain
cells in an area that's critical for
learning and memory call the hippocampus
more specifically they had a higher
amount of support cells called glia
which provide nutrients and protect
other brain cells against inflammation
there are correlations with that being
associated with more adaptive and
effective cognition fun fact one study
found that this guy also had more glial
cells in his brain I mean maybe we had
Little Einstein raccoons basically the
very things that make Rack Room so hard
to control and manage in a lab are the
biggest reasons why they're so critical
to study like humans they're very
adaptable meaning they can switch up
their strategies when one stops working
that's known as cognitive flexibility
okay so in this experiment scientists
are using Cutting Edge electronic
tagging and 90 vision technology to
study raccoons in the wild they built a
box with 12 latch doors and behind each
door there was a tree they were
surprised to find that the raccoons were
able to come up with different ways of
opening the doors which really speaks to
you know both flexibility and
individuality in their problem solving
in this test raccoons had to learn which
button dispensed food
[Music]
and then adjust when that button stopped
working
the aggressive raccoons struggled but
the calmer ones did much better
according to Lauren it's that cognitive
flexibility that allows the raccoons to
adapt and thrive in unpredictable
environments like cities it's also
relevant for how we deal with raccoons
whether they're climbing on our
buildings or trying to get into our
stuff there's just this big million
dollar question out there that our city
is making animals smarter are we somehow
selecting for or shaping the types of
cognitive abilities that we think make
animals so successful in urban
environments what are you guys doing
unfortunately Lauren doesn't have a
definitive answer yet so what's next for
raccoons and Neuroscience Kelly wants to
build an atlas of raccoon brains like
the ones that exist for rodents and
humans that would help neuroscientists
come up with new and better experiments
comparing raccoon brains to ours